oh boy this is old school you ever think
about updating a bit it's pretty old
school
i only ever went to one school hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we'll be taking a look
at fitness youtuber johanna sophia from
grow with joe now first let me tell you
quickly about my sponsor squarespace i
know i talk about squarespace a lot over
here but i get so many questions about
how to quickly scale an online business
and i do think that it does start with a
website or blog squarespace is an
all-in-one platform whether you're
looking to build a website blog online
store or use their marketing tools and
analytics they have some awesome
extensions for e-commerce that really
allow you to promote your products and
streamline bookkeeping collect payments
and donations as well as link up your
social media accounts so that really
everything is working together
seamlessly honestly i always say that
the best use of your time is in your
business not in putting together a
complicated website so if you're looking
to start up a new business or passion
project this year and need a website to
get started check out squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain now
before we get into it feel free to pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with distorted
eating as always definitely feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are new here
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out and also hit me
up over on my social media platforms
over at abby's kitchen on instagram and
on tick tock if you are not already
following the fun all right let's jump
in
[Music]
i've seen this like pesto egg
trend on tick tock and on instagram so
i'm like
i gotta give these a try
one cup of juice okay so joe starts her
morning with some gentle movement by
doing a 30 minute incline walk and then
doing some stretches and it looks like
it was done fasted she just had some tea
beforehand but joe does say in the
description of this video that she
really only follows intermittent fasting
when it's convenient for her and seeing
as this all is happening so early i
think she got up at like four or
something it's quite possible that she's
just not super hungry first thing in the
morning and maybe she'd rather just eat
her breakfast post-workout when she can
really sit down with her family to enjoy
and digest i definitely can relate to
that now considering that this isn't
like a super long high intensity workout
and she's not waiting hours after
working out to eat i would say that
working out fast it is really not a
concern to me if that's what feels good
to her it works for me now as for her
breakfast we are getting some protein
and healthy fats from the pesto eggs and
maybe some cooking oil i'm not really
sure if she added any there but we do
have more fats plus fiber in the avocado
and a little additional fiber and
micronutrients from the veg and then of
course some carbs in the fresh juice now
i know i usually have something to say
about juicing in these influencers
videos time to
juice um and that's because juicing does
remove the beneficial fibers that
promote regularity and satiety so
especially when weight loss is the goal
i do think it makes much more sense to
eat the whole food more often but by
pairing the juice with the protein fat
and fiber from her meal aka the hunger
crushing combo we're actually going to
help to promote more long-lasting energy
and prevent a subsequent energy crash so
if you love your juice amazing i
actually think that juice is a really
convenient source of micronutrients and
of course carbs but ideally we want to
pair those carbs with those hunger
crushing compounds as joe did to make a
more satiating meal or snack i actually
eat first thing in the morning
with my family and mainly because i like
to eat with my family i like to um
be on the same kind of timing as them
yeah there are some mechanisms that can
help you lose fat
when you intermittent fast but
ultimately what you want to be doing is
making sure that your calorie intake
is lower than maintenance if you want to
lose weight
higher than maintenance if you want to
gain weight or gain lean muscle
and at maintenance if you want to
maintain yep 100
i discussed this in a lot more detail in
my video on intermittent fasting right
here but i would say that missing out on
social eating experiences is really one
of the primary reasons why a lot of
intermittent fasters quit and like joe i
am a big believer in prioritizing family
meals as research suggests they have a
number of physical social and emotional
health benefits for our kids and
ourselves now when it comes to balancing
that with the benefits of intermittent
fasting the good news is that it's kind
of an easy trade-off in my books at
least so research suggests that while
there may be some metabolic mechanisms
that would theoretically give fasting an
edge in the weight loss race in real
life outcomes aren't really that much
different from any other calorie
restricted diet the main reason people
lose weight while fasting is not because
of insulin suppression it's because
we're just kind of bad at making up for
meals that we skip so i'm glad that joe
is finding a weight loss method that
works for her that doesn't compromise on
that important family time one more
thing that i try to do every morning is
not have any simple carbs or simple
sugars
this helps me throughout the rest of the
day not feel like i
crave them all right let's talk carbs
101 so
some people like to simply categorize
carbs into simple and complex simple
carbs like glucose lactose fructose and
sucrose as there are others as well are
made up of shorter chains of sugar
molecules which make them quite easy and
quick to digest then complex carbs aka
starches are formed by longer sugar
chains and therefore take longer to
break apart and digest so while it is
true that simple carbs found things like
candy and sugary drinks and baked goods
and table sugar will likely leave you
hungry or i guess craving more food soon
after there are also a lot of simple
carbs in nutritious satiating foods like
fruit milk dairy and vegetables as well
the key difference here is that the
simple carbs in produce and dairy are
bound up by hunger crushing compounds
like protein fat and fiber so this is
why sometimes these like little sound
bites like diet rules don't always shake
out in real life in fact joe actually
broke her own rules when she drank the
simple carb packed juice at breakfast
but that's really no big deal in my
books because again she paired it with a
meal that was rich in hunger crushing
compounds as we already discussed which
helped to really buffer the blood sugar
response this is all just to say that we
really can't paint simple sugars or
simple carbs with the same brush as
something we need to avoid because in
doing so we're also excluding a lot of
nutrient-dense foods so it's so much
better to look at the meal or the diet
holistically rather than parsing it into
individual ingredients and rules as for
her suggestion that eating simple carbs
in the morning can cause you to crave
carbs all day long there's nothing
unique about simple carbs that cause any
specific cravings it's more just that
they don't keep you very satiated on
their own for very long so of course
your blood sugar levels take a dip and
then we instinctively go hunting for
some more carbohydrates to bring it back
up and then of course our energies on
this like bumpy ride for the rest of the
day
now there is however some really good
quality research speaking to the
importance of having a source of protein
for breakfast especially when your goal
is to lose weight so research suggests
that consuming protein at breakfast
significantly can help to reduce
appetite and subsequent caloric intake
at meals later on in the day protein
really is the king in the satiety
hierarchy so ensuring that we have a
source of protein in that meal can help
to get us to that next meal without
feeling the effects of an energy crash
so as always it isn't about taking away
the simple naked carbs it's about
dressing them up with a source of
protein so something that i try to do is
have my breakfast high in
fats a protein and then i have carbs
like the tomatoes and mushrooms that are
not simple carbs they're more complex
yes and no while mushrooms are
technically considered complex carbs
because they contain polysaccharides
like chitin and beta glucans and banan's
about 70 of the carb content in tomatoes
comes from simple sugars like glucose
and fructose not that any of that really
matters in my books because like she
said these are low calorie and therefore
relatively quite low carb foods and
those simple carbs are also easily
buffered by the other hunger crushing
compounds on the plate nutrition is all
about the big picture
gonna be taking my pre-workout
half a scoop
um
i'm just gonna dry scoop it i would not
suggest this
if you have never tried pre-workout
[Music]
[Music]
ah the dry scoop trend of tick tock
yikes now this has become a super
controversial trend among the fitness
community as dry scooping pre-workout
supplements have actually led to some
pretty serious health concerns like
choking from accidental inhalation
respiratory issues and dehydration most
pre-workouts also contain a pretty
concentrated dose of caffeine so
excessive consumption especially on its
own like that can have some potentially
dangerous effects according to buzzfeed
one 20 year old woman actually suffered
a heart attack after dry scooping while
another report by newsweek suggested a
woman went to the er for high blood
pressure and brain swelling now i'm not
substantiating any of those claims but
absolutely these things can happen and
even if you're taking a pre-workout
according to the label instructions it's
important to note that a lot of folks
complain of side effects like tingling
and flushing from the beta alanine and
niacin not to mention the supplement
world is grossly unregulated and there
have been a lot of lawsuits related to
banned substances and contaminants being
found in fitness supplements like this
so if you're using a pre-workout or any
supplement for that matter look for a
third-party tested product read the
label carefully and please
use it as directed i am having this
chopped kit sunflower crisp i'm going to
be adding some veggie burger on top and
for larry i'm making pasta
he's having the five cheese
tortellini i have this salad
i put some beets in there i also put um
the veggie burger in there sauerkraut
pepitas and um cranberry this is how
larry's lunch turned out and then i'm
just gonna add a little extra cheese on
top for him okay so for lunch we've got
a quickie chopped salad from a salad kit
which is honestly the real mvp in my
book so joe dresses hers up by adding a
veggie patty and pumpkin seeds for some
protein and fats and we got some fiber
and carbs from the beets cranberries and
veg now seeing as this is a post-workout
meal and she's hit it pretty hard she
went to the gym and the pool at this
point today i would suggest a little
more calories and carbs now i know she
made her hubby a big plate of amazing
looking pasta which she's not eating
well i'm not sure how it would work so
well in the bootable i do think there's
absolutely room for a side plate of
pasta here even with her goal to lose
weight and if she didn't want the pasta
she could easily add in some quinoa or
rice sweet potato or just double down on
the fruit to make it really super easy
we ideally want to get like a one to
four ratio of protein to carbs after a
workout to help replenish those glycogen
stores and help drive protein into the
muscle faster so i would say if she were
to really focus on carbs anywhere in her
day it should be here it's still a
couple more hours till cousin goes to
sleep so i'm needing a little boost of
energy i got some grapes these are a
great quick source of energy as they
have fructose in them um so they're a
little bit higher in the simple sugars
but they're a great quick source of
energy and then i'm having a little less
than a handful of nuts and this is a
little bit of a longer lasting source of
energy and by a little bit i mean a lot
more first of all i have no qualms about
snacks
i i think snacks are a really important
way to help you get the nutrients that
you need in the day especially for
highly active people like joe but i do
think that had we had more carbs and
more calories in that post-workout meal
that we'd actually likely have a bit
more energy to perhaps get us to dinner
now while protein is king in the satiety
hierarchy like i said we really can't
forget that carbs are quite literally
energy and yes we can derive energy from
fat allah ketosis but there is nothing
quite like the og now having said that i
think that this is a really beautiful
balanced snack we've got some protein
healthy fats and fiber from the nuts
plus some extra energizing carbs and
fiber in the grapes but i gotta say
like do we really
need to constantly label foods as simple
carbs or complex carbs feels exhausting
getting sleepy huh
no while she's not wrong in pointing out
that grapes contain fructose is it
really that helpful to narrow our focus
down to this singular food component
because it's kind of missing the forest
from the trees and by trees i mean
antioxidants fiber energy flavor and fun
i really don't think we need another
good food versus bad food dichotomy to
have to obsess over especially if it
means demonizing something as nutritious
as fruit so it's dinner time today i
made
some sweet potato fries
i am sauteing some brussels sprouts here
and then i also made some chicken
tenderloins and i made a little sauce
basically just ketchup honey and
sriracha so it's like a sweet and sour
and spicy
[Music]
okay so we've got another solid family
meal here with some fiber-rich carbs
from the sweet potato we got protein
from the chicken and some veggie and
fiber action from the brussels sprouts
now it is a little low in fat as i'm not
sure if she's cooking with any oil in
there i know dieters are traditionally
quite hesitant to cook in oils or fats
but i would say two teaspoons spread
over two people is only like 40 calories
a person but it adds so much to the
texture flavor and satisfaction factor
obviously i think we can be smart about
added oil especially in the context of
weight loss but we don't need to
completely cut it out now aside from
that i do think it seems like a little
bit confusing that joe was so adamant to
call out every source of simple sugar in
this video while coating the chicken in
ketchup and honey i have nothing against
ketchup or honey i mean we eat ketchup
with our side fries in my house but
there's just a lot of mixed messages
going on and i really don't think joe
needs to worry so much about the whole
simple versus complex carb situation
when incorporating it into balanced
meals like this if you find that you are
struggling with eating the right things
or fueling yourself properly is
something that you can do is look up
complex carbs and healthy fats so
complex carbs are the ones that you want
to lean on a lot of people if they're
asking if you're asking them how do i
lose weight how do i lose fat they're
going to say cut out carbs don't cut out
carbs completely make sure that you're
keeping your carbs there this is going
to give you energy it's going to feel
your muscles it's going to help you fill
out your muscles but make sure you lean
on complex carbs another thing is the
healthy fats you're going to want to
make sure that um you look those up as
well find a list of healthy fats that
you can have joe is not wrong here i
mean studies suggest that like 50 to 55
of calories from carbs is really the
ultimate sweet spot when we see a
decreased rate of mortality in the
research and while we definitely want to
prioritize higher fiber carbs like
starchy vegetables and whole grains
simple sugars also have their place
especially actually in supporting
exercise recovery as for her mention of
healthy fats while we did see her
incorporate some healthy fats like
avocado and like nuts and seeds into her
day it is hard to tell if she's cooking
with any avocado oil or extra virgin
olive oil or any dressing like she
mentions also while fats are technically
an energy source they're more of like a
backup source of stored energy when
we've kind of used up our glycogen
stores so in other words if you're
already eating enough carbs in your day
that really wouldn't be the body's first
choice for energy fuel but we do want to
lean on healthy fats for satiety cell
growth organ protection and help absorb
our fat soluble vitamins like vitamins a
k d and e you find that you're eating a
lot of sweets or a lot of processed
foods then maybe you just need to take a
step in the right direction sometimes it
just takes a couple days for you to
start loving healthier foods again try
and push yourself to get through those
first few days and then as you keep
going it's gonna get easier and easier
and you're gonna find that you're gonna
enjoy
healthy foods more
i think i get what she's trying to say
but i'm not sure i fully agree with this
strategy most people are not going to be
able to push through a state of
deprivation and like uncomfortable
pressuring and then find themselves on
the other side magically loving foods
that they forced themselves to eat i
mean there is a reason why most diets
fail we just don't like pushing
ourselves to do things that are
unpleasant or uncomfortable like it
literally sets us up for a binge now as
i discuss in my sustainable weight loss
video right here rather than focusing on
what you should avoid or take away which
tends to elicit like a scarcity
mentality and trigger a binge i like
instead to focus on what we can add to
our meals to really optimize them so for
example if you love sweets and you enjoy
a sweet muffin or pastry in the morning
why not add in some yogurt or some
poached eggs that way you still get the
emotional satisfaction from your pastry
as well as getting the physical
nourishment and satiety from the other
hunger crushing compounds also rather
than pushing yourself to like something
why not find a way to make it enjoyable
for yourself if you don't like boiled
brussels sprouts in just like plain old
water then roast them in some olive oil
add some maple syrup do something to
make it taste better to you so that
deserves like a whole other video but if
you want some more tips on how to turn
your meals into hunger crushing
compounds check out my video
right here so all that said what are my
overall thoughts on joe's diet on this
particular day joe is consuming roughly
1500 calories which based on my
calculations is likely a pretty
significant deficit considering the
volume of training she did in one day
and while this day in particular is
fairly low in carb probably because of
this nonsensical no simple carbs rule
she does have three balanced meals with
a snack and she doesn't restrict any
major food groups so i definitely got to
give the girl props for that i would
however love to see her relax her whole
no simple carb rule not only is this
advice outdated and incomplete but she
herself contradicts her own advice
throughout this video with her food
choices and then goes off on simple
carbs as like the root cause of weight
gain while warning people not to quote
her on that now i don't want to
discredit joe for her weight loss
efforts or knowledge in the fitness
space but i do think it's important to
recognize that we do have a
responsibility as content creators for
the suggestions that we make and i have
no issues with people sharing what they
eat in day or even labeling their vlog
as like what to eat to lose weight but
in this video joe is explicitly giving
out nutrition advice and a lot of it
isn't necessarily scientifically sound
or at least it's overly simplified and
contradictory in a lot of cases i don't
think this is purposeful deception i
just think that she doesn't necessarily
understand the nuance herself and it is
very complicated so i get that but it
would be a lot more useful i think to
stick to what she said at the top of
this video which was you know eat fewer
calories to lose weight and eat more
calories to gain weight and then if she
maybe want to throw in that eating more
protein or a more protein rich diet is
helpful for keeping her full i think
that also makes sense but there's no
need to demonize simple carbs and then
eat
said simple carbs it's just confusing to
the lay person
my tip is just to tweak the language
here and i say let's shift the focus to
dressing up those naked carbs to make
them into more satiating meals and
snacks think about balance think about
satiety and yes if weight loss is your
goal think about creating a modest
caloric deficit in a gentle and
nutritionally supportive way without
triggering scarcity mentality and i've
got lots of tips on how to try to do
that in my weight loss video right here
and on that note that's all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye